hello there you are watching the press
preview a first look at what's on the
front pages as they arrive it's time to
see what's making the headlines with the
sun's political editor harry cole and
the guardian's chief political
correspondent jessica elgot they'll be
with us from now until just before
midnight
so let's see what's on some of those
front pages for you now
the financial times leads on the bank of
england's warning of a 15-month
recession and that inflation set to hit
13
with the guardian highlighting the rise
in interest rates
the male is accusing the governor of the
bank of england of being asleep at the
wheel on their front page
families are warned of tightening purse
strings as the telegraph's headline
reads recession to cause record drop in
income
that's also the lead story for the metro
their headline the big squeeze
the eye has followed suit and amid that
inflation morning the express says it's
time to batten down the hatches
while the mirror asks why the prime
minister and chancellor are on holiday
as the bank announces the hike
meanwhile the star contrasts the bad
news of inflation with the good the
return of the premier league
the sun however leads on former love
island winner ken macetine's involvement
in a road collision
and a reminder that by scanning the qr
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us
and tonight we are joined by the sun's
political editor harry cole and the
guardian's chief political correspondent
jessica elgot welcome to you both let's
start with the financial times bank of
england uh their prediction of a
recession and the interest rate hike
let's start with you harry
yeah about as grim a day of economic
news as you can get which you soon act
said tonight on the sky debate uh the
red lights
are on the dashboard of our flashing and
i think that's somewhat of an
understatement
um massive rates rise predicted in 13
um inflation and 15 months
of uh of recession that is not as deep
as the 2008 one but as bad as the one
in the 90s now
um lots of questions remarks over how
that will be dealt with by the two
candidates um tonight but um lots of
question marks also about who's dealing
with it
now the the chancellor um not in it as
his destiny putting out statements
working from
wherever he is uh but not at his desk of
the treasury and the prime minister also
on holiday so all in all a pretty grim
day and um one that
opens up more questions than it answers
yes uh jessica what do you make of the
fact that both the prime minister and
the chancellor not around at this very
very important time
i mean it certainly feels like that the
government's hung the out of office uh
sign on the front door of uh of number
10 down the street and the people you
know any kind of reassurance and and
bear in mind ordinary people seeing
these headlines on the front of every
newspaper people who already feel like
they're out of credit at the end of the
month um and and they can't and their
budgets can't take anymore they can't
take you know even throughout the rising
energy bills but this the soaring
inflation
um and to hear you know practically
nothing from the from from the people in
charge
and only hear um disagreement about the
way forward from the people who are
buying to lead the country
and also and very little from from
either of them about what directly
they're going to do on the first day um
in number 10 to help people
not you know go go into the go into the
red and stay in the red
and suffer because of that
the guardian pointing to the 13
warning inflation will hit that that
figure um harry what did you make of how
both candidates um responded to this in
our debate
this evening
yeah i look russian acts in a in an
unenviable position because obviously
until two weeks ago god it feels about
two years until two weeks ago he was um
three weeks ago he was still the
chancellor now
whether right or wrong i think he's
gonna struggle to distance himself from
some of the economic policy decisions
made yes the bank is independent but um
you know there was a time when this
government certainly the prime minister
was talking down the prospect of soaring
inflation in recent uh in in recent
months let's trust you know to her
credit she did say today look this isn't
inevitable recession is not inevitable
despite what the bank's warning the
bank's saying if nothing else if nothing
changes now this is what's going to
happen
richie sunak said little well you know i
have to wait and see but my my i don't
want to make anything worse but i think
you know trust is saying well actually
no like if this this horror is coming
down the tracks maybe we should at least
try something um in order to in order to
at least try and stave off but go for
growth now try and cut taxes now put
more money into people's pockets with an
uh by reversing the national insurance
rise in five weeks time to try and to
try and basically ease some of the cost
of living pain whether or not this could
be enough i i doubt it very much but um
what my big takeaway tonight was
actually i was really struck by sunak
saying actually i'm not going to say
what i'm going to do in fact i might not
do anything all i will do is i'll i
promise i'll help out somehow but i need
to look at the numbers i need to look at
the numbers in six weeks time well
actually the numbers are pretty stark
today and i don't think to be able to
get through the next five weeks without
putting a bit more flesh on those bones
of what his plan is beyond saying don't
vote those trust
jessica do you agree with harry that uh
sunaku will struggle to distance himself
from economic policy that's gone before
bearing in mind that he was the
chancellor up until a few weeks ago
yeah absolutely i mean harry's
absolutely right i mean it's it's it's
very it's very difficult for you to to
run on your record when you know today
is is you know but it's not only was she
sunk's fault but you know it is he's the
person who's been in charge of the
public purse for the last two years
and and his answers you know to it which
he's announced including things like
cutting v80 off in energy bells that's
something that might have more of a
direct impact on on on household bills
but it's something he rejected as
chancellor time and time again you know
when he had the power to do it in number
11 he said that he wouldn't do it and so
to come out now and say that that's
what's you know something that he would
do in the autumn when it's some
something you already have the power so
you did say
see
he did say during the course of the
debate that um he did differ with boris
johnson on on economic policy and
actually that was the ultimate reason
that he left that they were going in
different directions so does that not
distance him from what's gone before
i mean i think one of one of the things
that they they clearly had big
differences of opinions on was was that
was immediate tax cuts and and and soon
axe you know not wrong he hasn't
reversed on on that front he's said that
he doesn't think that he could you know
consistent that that he thinks tax cuts
would be inflationary uh which is which
is the big dividing line in this contest
let's move on to the metro i mean
they're all on the um
financial theme bank of england governor
andrew bailey uh pictured there uh the
big squeeze is their headline um and
there's there's no other way to describe
it is there harry
no i think you know people thinking
things are bad now um you know what it's
gonna feel like they're still saying
inflation's gonna be possibly double
digits this time next year and that's
you know
a catastrophic effect on people's pay
packets and their wages and their bills
on their on their cost of living um this
isn't clearly isn't something that's
going to go away anytime soon and there
has to be a point in the the sunax
defense is he's already you know
essentially given 1 600 pounds to the
porous porous households in britain lots
of lots of support already made
available but it just looks like a drop
in the ocean it will feel like a drop in
the ocean and you have to wonder at what
point do you end up getting to a sort of
almost like a re-launch not a real
furlough scheme but something of that
scale
in order to
um in order to protect people from the
price rises not just now but the ones
coming down the line the
the predictions the experts the
economists are saying you know this is
going to reach the price cap is going to
reach 3 500 pounds a year and that's
people are just unable to afford that
there's already whispers and and
campaigns being launched of saying look
you can't you can't you can't they can't
prosecute everyone if everyone stops
paying i was really struck by a caller
uh on one of the talk radio stations
today he was basically in tears saying
i i i can i don't know i want to be a
law abiding citizen but i also want to
feed my children and there's nothing i
can do i can i if i have to choose
between food for my children and giving
bp and shell and and energy companies
you know five times the amount that they
were paying a year ago the the ethical
and moral decision is right there but if
that makes them a criminal then so be it
i think that's going to be a horrible
debate that's going to be by the end of
this year being had up and down the
country and the government are going to
have to at the moment i'm not hearing it
from any of the leadership contenders
that they've even grasped the scale of
this and the the the size of what's
coming down the line yes the prediction
of a 15-month recession is no joke i
mean do you
also
agree jessica that uh this wasn't really
something that either candidate this
evening
really got into
i do think that there is there is not
i didn't get a sense from and i haven't
throughout the whole campaign got a
sense of the you know the the immediate
urgency i mean this
of what is coming down the track for
these candidates i mean this is going to
be on their desk from day one that this
is that that you know that the price
rise is coming we're potentially
facing people mass defaulting on their
bills you know a friend of mine was was
only telling me this morning that she
been told that her estimated monthly
bill is going up from 170 pounds a month
to 450 pounds a month which is something
she says she's just not prepared to pay
and she's going to cancel a direct debit
and just pay the you know try and pay
the bills quarterly instead and i think
you will see you know people trying
people saying well i'm just not prepared
to pay that much i'm just going to keep
paying the amount i was paying before
and i i'll cancel my direct debits and
and and seeing that kind of thing happen
in the autumns and you know the a new
prime minister who's got to reckon with
that reality with businesses going bust
because they can't pay their energy
bills with potentially ma you know more
mass industrial action because
workers are demanding pay rises and
rightly so because you know people's
people's pay is just not worth as much
as it as it was and people are being
pushed into poverty and
you know this is this is an
extraordinary challenge coming down the
line and there is no one who seems to
have
you know particularly radical
new solutions to to try and deal with it
and trying to protect people what is
certain whoever becomes prime minister
they are going to have an incredibly
difficult ship to to steer jessica and
harry for the moment thank you we are
going to take a break coming up
missing in action says mirror we'll take
a closer look at that story after the
break
[Music]
welcome back you're watching the press
preview still with me the sun's
political editor harry cole and the
guardian's chief political correspondent
jessica algot welcome back to both of
you let's have a look at
the sun harry um and um
the the headline this is on page four
into the paper government goes awol in
crunch crisis to what
is the paper referring
well it was a bit weird today is it that
the first time we had any proper real
response that wasn't uh a three-line
quote emailed out by the chancellor was
when we're seeing the the two people who
are vying to be the next prime minister
rather than you say the actual prime
minister you think the scale of the news
today would have perhaps required a bit
more of a formal response from the the
ministers that many will hold
responsible there's a big argument that
you know andrew bailey has been awol
he's on 600 grand a year his job is that
he is tasked with keeping inflation at
two percent and he stood up today and
said actually he's gonna be 13 without a
hint of you know any contrition or the
fact that maybe he would perhaps should
perhaps be resigning as well um but the
chancellor's on holiday he says he's
working from wherever he is he's with
his family but he's never off duty and
boris johnson's on his honeymoon so
there is just a feeling that you know
are we really gonna let this drag on for
five more weeks but because although
we're seeing the candidates day in day
out and they're talking about the things
they're going to do and want to do
um it feels like the ship is pretty
rudderless right now and it feels to me
that this leadership election could have
been wrapped up in perhaps three weeks
and actually the government could get on
with governing again now rather than
throwing rocks at each other uh jessica
do you think that the public still
expect to hear from
the prime minister knowing that he's on
his way out the chancellor perhaps given
but the the prime minister we know that
he no longer will be come the beginning
of september
i think you know it's not like this it's
not like today's announcement is a
massive surprise you know the the these
rate you know the interest rates review
is is due today we always knew that the
news was going to be bad it's been
particularly bad but you might have
thought that the chancellor would have
thought it might be important to be
around
for this particular announcement um
which has been long scheduled and that
he might have thought that taking a
family holiday or at least joining his
family on holiday could wait you know a
couple of days until until this was over
just because he's you know because he
could appear on broadcast he could
answer people's questions about it you
know he's he's not you know nadine's aha
he hasn't been in the in number 11 very
long he may not stay in number 11 very
long but this is a fairly crucial moment
of his time in that office it's a very
important office and i don't think it's
beyond
you know the i don't think it's beyond
a reason to expect him to be there for
for when it happens well we didn't have
the the prime minister or the chancellor
this evening but we did have the
leadership contenders um and rishi sunak
suggested that uh les truss's plans
may make things worse for the economy
what did you make of that harry
yeah he's this is the central mantra of
his entire
um pitch the voters it turns out it's
not necessarily a picture that the
voters want to hear there's a
fascinating poll by redfield and wilton
out tonight which we've got in our paper
tomorrow which shows that actually for
the first time
that liz trust would beat kierstarma in
a in a in a poll uh of the general
public at a general election but kirsten
would beat rishi soon act look i
i have some sympathy for sunaki he's
trying to make his case very clear he's
very passionate believes that he should
tackle inflation first and then tax cuts
can come tomorrow i think where he's
gone wrong
is it's this idea that there is actually
there is a live debate about this but
his campaign is a little bit hectoring
it's a little bit like george osborne
back in 2016 or the tories in 2015. it's
not that you know he's not saying it
it's not saying that well i disagree
with liz he's saying liz is a moral for
not agreeing with him and no one likes
to be hectic like that especially not by
the guy who's had his hands on the
tiller all right for the last two years
yes he was dealing with a crimes but it
just needs to have a bit of humbleness
we must leave it there unfortunately our
studio audience as we we saw they um
gave wishy sunak the edge um thank you
both harry and jessica for the moment
good to see